hey guys is Daniel here from D LM model
lifestyle
I'm here with photographer Nikita I'll
add a link in the description so you can
check out her photos today in this video
I'm gonna show you how to do male model
poses for men I thought it's better to
do it while we're doing the photo shoot
so then you can see how it looks like in
real life so let's start of the basics
[Music]
so what is mariposas well it's just you
basically facing the camera and showing
your vest angles to get a good shot now
the first thing that you need to get
used to these people in the background
whether you're in location shoots or in
the studio there's going to be some
people looking at you all the time so
you have to get used to this there's a
lot of factors that comes into posing
it's not just you
he's the type of lights the type of
photographer it's the location that you
are playing with it the clothes that you
have on the hairstyle that you have is a
lot of things but today is just the
basics so we are just working on the
basic modeling poses and what you want
to do is you're going to remember these
angles the front angle left 45 and right
25 these are your main three angles the
left side might be better or suppose on
your right side might be better it
depends on your angles but mostly you
use these three angles where you look
there into the camera 45 degrees to the
left and 25
the second thing that you need to
remember is that not everybody is so
natural in front of the camera for some
it is very natural to pose it from the
camera and for some it takes a little
bit of crack so don't be too hard on
yourself just get used to it and then
once you get those three angles down
there are three different causes main
causes standing just normal standing
pose then you have walking poses as well
so you can play around with it a little
bit the third tip that I can give you is
you add these different angles which is
different kind of poses so whether
you're walking or you're standing or if
you're sitting down do it in all these
different angles of course there are
more so you can look at the camera turn
the kitties and look totally 90 degrees
and add something interesting but I'll
talk a lot about those kind of things
later on in some other videos subscribe
if you want to check those up anyway
that's good let's get back to the basic
beginner I've met male model poses so
you walk stand a little bit keep
different directions alright so one
thing that you need to remember
is the direction and angle of your face
it's very important your body has these
three angles right but with your face
you can look everywhere like you will
look in real life so let's do a few
where I just stand left 45 degrees
direction look at how many different
poses I can do by just changing my face
and a little bit of my body
[Music]
you need to remember talk refer you
should move as well some shoot very fast
so you need to move while they shoot and
normally you hear it click sound and
then you know the photos done so you
changed some photographers take a long
time to focus and others they do it fast
so you can just keep on moving and they
get their their shots in play around
with your hands clear under if your face
expressions look far look near look to
the camera and play with your body you
see up your body and your face they play
together they work together to get a
good picture with the type of clothes
that you have another thing that you
need to remember is photographer comes
closer to you it usually is just upper
body shot but if they're a little bit
further away you know it's a full body
shot
so when Nikita is close like this you
have to remember to play your
expressions and keep your upper body in
different directions like this it
doesn't matter how you look here from
this part here down sometimes you can
move a lot and keep these interesting
poses working with the clothes and with
your hands but sometimes just normal
basic poses is really good
just standing and looking at different
directions so there's a lot of different
handbooks that you can do if the
photographer's close to you like this
bring your hands up a little bit play
around so these are upper body shots but
if the Tuggerah wants to do two length
shots play around relax don't do this
gonna last 45 to the camera but make the
model really good if you have big
variety of model poses now you need to
learn how to pose in different
directions different facial expressions
of different clothes the best tip is
natural is best I'm gonna pose for you
just natural poses without even putting
my hands in my pockets are really using
them I'm just gonna use the angles 45
degrees to the left to the camera 45
degrees to the right walking and
standing pose that's it look how that's
that
[Music]
alright guys there you have it now you
know how to do male modeling poses for
beginners but before you go I just want
to give a big thanks to Nikita she's an
awesome awesome photographer I don't
link in the description so you can check
out her work there's also my wife which
is pretty awesome because I can get new
test shoots whenever I want but thank
you so much for checking out this video
if you want to see some more videos
about modeling please subscribe and I'll
see you in the next video